Навчання Sea Breeze-2019.
Сьогодні ми знаходимося на американському есмінці Carney
і будемо говорити про ці навчання і про ситуацію в Чорному морі
з заступником командира есмінця Дагласом Рено.
- Доброго дня.
Перше питання - про Ваше українське коріння.
Ми знаємо, що Ваша родина походить із України...
- Так, я наполовину українець по лінії матері.
Моя родина - з містечка Нью-Брітен у штаті Коннектикут.
Там багато місцевих жителів, які емігрували з Західної України
на початку 20-х років минулого століття.
Мій дідусь, а також його п'ятеро братів народилися у Сполучених Штатах.
Вони воювали під час Другої світової в армії й ВМС США.
Мій дідусь був одним із керівників неурядової організації
Українські Американські Ветерани, тож я зростав
у такій родині, відзначаючи українські свята та відвідуючи українську церкву.
- Чи вперше Ви берете участь у навчаннях?
- Так, я вперше на Чорному морі та вперше на навчаннях Sea Breeze.
- Чи можете Ви оцінити, як підготовлені українці?
- Я дуже вражений підготовкою українських військових.
Вони сповнені ентузіазму.
Ми одразу занурилися в навчання.
Вони привітні й дуже нас підтримують, зокрема в Одесі.
- Чи можна з українцями відпрацьовувати навчання такого рівня, як Sea Breeze?
- Так, вони - одні з найсильніших наших партнерів
у Чорноморському регіоні.
Всі їхні кораблі дуже добре себе показали на морі.
Вони надали нашій команді дуже добрі можливості для тренувань на Sea Breeze.
- Існують певні загрози з боку Росії в Чорному морі.
Чи відчуваєте Ви ці загрози?
Приміром, цього разу під час цих навчань?
- Ми, звісно, знаємо, що тут присутні й інші кораблі
та літаки, які не беруть участі в навчаннях.
Поки наші інтеракції з росіянами були безпечними.
Ми моніторимо ситуацію.
- Чи готові Ви особисто до якогось стрімкого розвитку подій у разі,
приміром, якщо Росія вирішить зупинити ці навчання або якось зашкодити?
- Військово-морські сили США завжди готові
реагувати швидко на будь-які загрози в регіоні.
- Коли починалися ці навчання, можливо, есмінець
отримав наказ від свого штабу: в жодному разі
не переходити до якоїсь гарячої точки розвитку подій. Чи так це?
- У нас немає вказівок, окрім наших стандартних правил,
тож ми будемо реагувати згідно з тим,
як нас тренували, і залежно від загрози, яка постала.
- Сполучені Штати поступово нарощують свою присутність у Чорному морі.
Чи готові Ви особисто захищати Грузію чи Україну?
- Я готовий виконувати накази, які надходять до мене.
Я лише виконавець. Я не розробляю плани, а виконую їх.
Сполучені Штати виступають за підтримку стабільності в регіоні
та забезпечення вільного руху кораблів для всіх країн.
- Ми знаємо ситуацію навколо відносин України та Росії.
Як Ви думаєте, який захист потрібен тут, у Чорному морі,
щоб ці відносини не перейшли в якусь гарячу фазу?
- Я думаю, що продовження присутності та робота
з нашими регіональними партнерами.
Наша присутність - це фактор стримування.
Це саме те, що ми тут робимо.
- Росія називає появу есмінця в Чорному морі
"нахабством, демонстрацією сили". Що Ви можете відповісти на це?
- Ми діємо в різних водах, у міжнародних водах,
ми виконуємо навчання з нашими регіональними партнерами.
Ми не вважаємо провокацією те, як ми діємо.
- Можливо, у Вас є свої особисті оцінки щодо того,
що сталося з українськими моряками в Азовському морі?
- У мене немає особистої думки щодо цього.
Як моряку мені прикро бачити, як інші моряки
потрапили в халепу, але в мене немає особистої думки про це.
Що б Ви сказали, якби дізналися, що
українські моряки знову спробують пройти через Азовське море?
- Як я вже казав, я не розробляю лінію поведінки,
а виконую національну політику США і не можу коментувати це.
- Ви, можливо, були на березі в Одесі.
Чи відчуваєте Ви більше емоцій щодо своєї батьківщини фактично?
- Я ніколи не думав, що побачу Україну.
Я багато мандрував Європою,
але я вперше в Україні. Одеса - дуже красиве місто.
Дуже приємно бачити, які гостинні люди, вражаюча архітектура й кухня.
- Головний висновок  щодо цих навчань цього року який у Вас?
- У мене тільки позитивні враження.
Дуже класно співпрацювати з іншими країнами,
з якими в нас немає великого досвіду.
Наш капітан Янг брав участь у Sea Breeze кілька разів.
Для мене це перший раз. Бачити нашу співпрацю з іншими країнами -
це чудова можливість для наших офіцерів
потренуватися й покращити те, що ми робимо на морі щодня.
- Дуже дякую за інтерв’ю.